britt young fox news senior political
analyst brit
why now why is it why the change in tone
now
well i think for a couple reasons one of
them is donald trump was gone and trump
like
trump was uh partial to this idea you
remember he's the one who called it the
wuhan virus and and
and the ch and the chinese virus and so
that
which meant that for the left hating him
as they did
um that that idea of the of the thing
being something that china
uh was was causing china as a nation
because that's a government obviously a
government operation that lab
um was anathema people hated that idea
so
you know you didn't you didn't hear it
and it was scoffed at
it was said to have been debunked which
of course it never really had
um so that was a big piece of it the
other piece of it was that uh you know
there was this alternative theory
about you know how it sort of merged it
migrated from bats or pangolins or
whatever to
human beings which i guess can happen
but it's not you know
the problem was always brian that that
the theory that it was
that came out of that lab was plausible
on its face because the lab was there
and working on diseases of this kind is
what they did
so finally i think you know when we
finally heard you know in the wall
street journal for example the
the lab workers had gotten sick right
about the
time this was the outbreak began um it
reached a critical mass
and and you know the time had come to to
take it seriously as people are now
doing in a very real
revealing interview with dr mark siegel
it looks as though the former uh
former cdc director said they were
picked up now as they look at satellite
images and get some reports
they're seeing that this could have
started as early as september which
explained why new york was blitzed with
it first
and we had no idea what was hitting us
at the time meanwhile the cdc director
went on to talk about the follow-up
investigation that he wanted to do when
he was in office when donald trump
was in power and was unable to do
because he feels as though he was being
blocked
in many cases he talked about the
optimism he doesn't have
that the who will be leading a second
investigation listen
there is no doubt that who was highly
compromised by china
and and still is i don't think we can
have a meaningful
transparent investigation led by who
i think they're just too compromised
this is pretty sensational we're about
to have a second investigation at the
behest of the president united states
who asked his intelligence apparatus to
do it as well but they have no access i
don't know what they expect to do
and he's saying don't worry about it
nothing's going to come of it
well he's right i think he's right about
that and i think that it's it's
dismaying that that the bad
administration and these
western leaders have been meeting for
the past week all wanted the who
to be the lead party in the
investigation the who i think is
compromised
look back to the beginning of all this
when the wha was praising china for how
transparent it had been china has been
anything but transparent
the who really has no credibility uh
it's
it i think it is dominated by china and
so
my guess is this is never going anywhere
china's not going to cooperate with any
serious investigation it's not in their
interest
as they see it to do so so here we are
but i think the suspicion now and
that that china is responsible will be
enhanced
by its continuing the refusal to
cooperate and who knows what evidence
has already been destroyed
you know what how many people who might
have the answers have disappeared and so
on
so it's not something that i think
anybody has reason to be optimistic
about
so let's let's close with this something
we can control and what dr redfield said
i think was striking
he said i expect politicians to be
political i didn't expect scientists
and he felt as though politics was all
over the policy
when he was in office and that goes
right back to anthony fauci who
seemingly has disappeared over the last
week
your thoughts on his conclusion
well i look i used to be in to some
extent still am an admirer of dr fauci
but i think he's made a number of
serious mistakes in this
um and i think he's gone along when he
should have spoken the truth
let's take the example of masking for
example in the early going
he said publicly and in an email that
we've all seen
uh that mass really are not going to
protect you of the kind that we all have
you know you're talking about the blue
ones we all
all see because the droplets are too
small
they'll penetrate a mask they might
protect you he said publicly once from
some droplets getting through but
they're not going to give you the kind
of protection you want or need
i think that was true i think that's
exactly what he thinks you know he's
been around a long time
masks or nothing new he knows about them
or had reason to
and then now later he came along and
changed his mind completely about that
so
which is it i think he was right the
first time and i think that
his wobbling on wavering on that issue
is one example
of why his credibility is now diminished
and his refusal to thoroughly
uh investigate the wuhan link to this
whole thing
really strikes his culpability and
capability
i'm very curious to see how this goes my
hunch i know you admire
him but by the time his book comes out
in november he'll be totally
disgraced i really do brit thanks so
much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else